[Music]
so it's no secret I've got a soft spot
for sloths I found in this lot
appreciation society our motto being
fast is overrated
I think the sloth is the true king of
the jungle but but it's its reputation
has been besmirched for centuries ever
since it was first discovered people
have misunderstood sloths the first
explorers that went to the new world and
saw sloths described them in no
uncertain terms as absolute losers there
was a conquistador Spanish conquistador
I think he was the first to describe the
sloth said it was the stupidest animal
that could be found on the planet so
then they weren't saddled with a name
that speaks of sin and and just
misunderstood for an incredibly long
time and and again that they are an
animal that people think of as being
some kind of evolutionary loser because
they're slow we think that they are
therefore kind of stupid and useless and
well they can't run from danger so you
know how do they survive well they
actually survive very well indeed which
is why I think they are the true king of
the jungle because there was a survey
done in a Panamanian rainforest and they
found that it was something like a third
of the mammalian biomass in that
particular forest was made up of sloths
so that's like you take all the mammals
from the forest 1/3 1/3 of that mass
would have been taken up by sloths so
all the rest was all the rats all the
ocelots all the tape here's everything
else took up 2/3 third of it was sloths
which is just a huge amount I mean
that's a very successful creature partly
we just don't realize that because
they're very hard to see they're very
stealthy you know so one of the things
the great things about being really slow
is you don't really get noticed which if
you're trying not to be eaten is really
quite a good idea so monkeys for
instance you're always aware of monkeys
when they turn up there's a lot of
crashing around and fruit being thrown
to the ground and they may
a lot of noise the sloth is moving very
slow with extraordinary control I always
watch them and think wow the core
control of that animal is amazing it's
like watching Swan Lake in slow motion I
mean they really just move so
fantastically slowly but those slow
movements we think slip under the radar
of the harpy eagle as its swooping
around the canopy they simply don't get
noticed and I think one of the reasons
why the early explorers so misunderstood
the sloth is because they were viewing
it the wrong way up so I think when the
the conquistadors you know first arrived
in the new world they would have been
brought examples of animals they
wouldn't have gone into the jungle and
observed them in 6:u they would have
been brought animals and with the sloths
you know this is a an inverted quadruped
it it is designed it is it is evolved to
live its life upside down because that's
incredibly energy efficient if you are
if you live your life upside down the
only muscles that you really need to
work are these ones so they can hook on
and hang like a happy hairy hammock and
just get on with the bit the busy
business of digesting their very
undigestible food they're basically sort
of dangling fermenting bags of food and
but that upside down existence requires
very little energy so they've almost got
rid of the muscles that that like
triceps that hold us erect but they they
just have the muscles that you use to
sort of draw yourself along and you know
when I'm at rest sitting in this chair
I'm using quite a lot of muscles to hold
myself up right but sloths don't need
any of those so when the early explorers
saw were brought sloths of course they
were taken out of their context they
were no longer
dangling from the tree the thing about
the inverses existence as it requires
50% around 50% of them
of an upright existence so it's much
more energy-efficient the problem is if
you turn a sloth the wrong way up
gravity removes its dignity and it
sprawls on the ground and is forced a
sort of like mountaineering on a flat
surface I mean it really is a pitiful
sight they sort of drag themselves along
like this and that of course would have
been how the early explorers would have
seen them as these sort of a ludicrous
quadrupeds you know that sort of
sprawled on the ground and Kant held its
hold itself up so I think that was where
this idea that they were they were
useless came from and and it's stuck
[Music]